una relación que sigue deteriorándose el
lunes la junta gobernante de malí
denunció el tratado de defensa vigente
con francia
desde hace algún tiempo el gobierno de
la república de malí observa actualizar
un profundo deterioro de la cooperación
militar con francia en 'twitter' el
gobierno de la república de malí ha
decidido denunciar el tratado de
cooperación en materia de defensa del 16
de julio de 2014
esto ocurre una semana después de que
malí acusar al ejército francés de
espionaje y su versión cuando usó un
dron para filmar lo que según francia
eran mercenarios enterrando cuerpos
cerca de una base militar por su parte
los franceses dijeron que sólo enviaron
el dron para refutar un tuit que acusaba
a las fuerzas francesas de dejar los
cuerpos en ese campamento el acuerdo de
defensa se había establecido después de
que francia desplegó un gran número de
tropas para ayudar a las fuerzas armadas
de malí a combatir la amenaza yihadista
en el país pero en febrero francia
decidió retirar sus tropas luego de una
escalada en las tensiones con la junta
militar
particularmente por sus estrechos
vínculos con el kremlin el anuncio se
produjo un día después de que el
secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres pidiera a la junta de malí así
como a las de burkina faso y guinea que
devolvieran el poder a los civiles lo
antes posible
coincidimos en la importancia de
proseguir el diálogo con las autoridades
de estos países
para garantizar el retorno al orden
constitucional lo antes posible
el secretario general de naciones unidas
antonio guterres defendió además la
importancia de la libertad de expresión
para garantizar una transición
democrática en mali la declaración se
produjo tras ser cuestionado por el veto
del gobierno golpista a los medios de
comunicación radio france internacional
y france 24 la junta de malí ha estado
en el poder desde agosto del 2020 y ha
anunciado que quiere que la transición a
la democracia dure 5 años